jon stewart's a perfect example and he's
been in the news lately where he went
completely crazy left the other day
where he used to be
i mean he'd be he if you look at some of
his older shows he's gonna be a
conservative considered today he used to
be moderate in the middle and he would
grab everyone and you joke about some
idiot saying something even the
republicans would be funny
and now you feel as though he knows that
he has to do these things to survive or
he will be you know cancelled just like
nancy pelosi is afraid aoc is going to
cancel her but these people are uh sad
no they are sad
because
you know what young people want
authenticity correct old people i guess
find john
you know you looked at some market
research and they said john i'm telling
you you got to go woke and be as racist
as you can against white people right
and then john's like i'm going to do it
and then the rest of us are just like
what happened to that guy right he lost
his audience that elon musk mean let me
let me pull that meme back up look at
this
this image right here this me in the
middle that's john stewart's fan base
right no straight up jon stewart praised
project veritas he mocked him a little
bit in funny ways like making fun of
james's clothing but said journalists
where are you look who's scooping you
how did these guys pull it off and then
he used the reporting legitimately not
ironically the acorn investigation
correct i like that i remember when he
came out in his pimp outfit for the
first time when he did his first show on
fox news i remember it to this day and
we did this whole write up about him and
you've watched as he you know and you're
listening to a google employee or
whoever he happens to be getting a cnn
employee producer saying yeah we lean
left and the next day somehow that isn't
what you just saw and that's what's
happening is i think the autism i think
people that are young
know this is all bs
you know you know what it is it's that
people like jon stewart bringing in an
audience who doesn't pay attention to
the news and then he says things and the
applause sign lights up right and
everyone's like yeah
and they used to be interview shows up
until 2006 the only way you're going to
see an actor talk about their experience
was on the tonight show or letter right
or something like that now they have
their own youtube channels they don't
need that crap junk now they're just
trying to fill the void right with
political and they have to try something
they have to
crap on trump it's just like the the
award shows i mean
you used to go to those for escapism and
now you know whatever is happening in
the media as far as politics on the on
the right you're just and then there was
the gay gay gay thing this time where
you know there was this gay bill and you
know everyone had to say gay gay gay um
and i think mo and you see the ratings
like
do you not see what you're doing no
one's watching you anymore because
they're they're tired it's exhausting
but it's but it's not true that's that's
the issue it's like when they're going
out and screaming gay everyone's like
why are you doing that right jankyuger
of the young turks he tweets out
conservatives claim to be pro free
speech but they literally celebrate a
bill called don't say gay and i'm like
bro the bill's not called that right and
he's like yeah well you don't speak out
against desantis for his anti-bds
legislation i was like we mentioned
almost every time we talk about desantis
we say it was bad
moving on i tweeted and
i said i think the gay don't say gabriel
might be the largest
fastest fake news in history because if
you were to look at it that day every
single headline started with don't say
gay bill and no one i had in this famous
fight with mark hamill i said did you
read the bill i had thousands of people
like coming at me you know because no
one read the bill you don't think mark
hamill read six pages of this bill it
just says you can't and then you're like
if you're going to pick a topic and as a
gay person trust me that came out in 88
we have a lot of things that we had to
overcome if you're going to pick arguing
over whether a k through third grades
can talk about sex you're you're gonna
i've said this in in
sully um what's his name said it too
um
you're going to set the whole cause back
25 years because i've seen a lot of
homophobic
stuff flow out since then now everyone's
this or that or pedophile or that let's
make this easy for people who aren't
familiar
i have no problem with critical race
theory books in schools i mean that
physically i have a problem with
critical race praxis in schools that is
in curriculum when teachers put critical
race theory in practice
in their lessons now if a school said
hey kids here we have the bible and here
we have kimberly crenshaw's critical
race theory we're going to analyze and
discuss these ideas i'd like that's cool
when they come out they don't do that
though what they actually do now is they
say the bible can't be in the school at
all but don't worry there's no critical
race theory here we just put those
lessons in the curriculum now imagine
this imagine if your kid went to school
one day and he came back with homework
and the homework said
jesus had 12 apostles one apostle
betrayed him how many apostles did not
betray him you'd be like well hold on
face
but but that's like the math problem
right it's a math question what is it on
the third day jesus rose 24 hours are in
one day how many hours did it take that
would be
praxis taking the teachings of religion
but putting it in math lessons right now
religious schools actually do this and
that's fine if you go to a religious
school in a public school i don't think
she'd have critical practice or
religious praxis but if the teachers
want to discuss any ideology i'm fine
with it i think the one good thing that
came out of the pandemic is that parents
figured out what their kids were
learning in school like you were just
off the kid goes and i mean these days
hoping they didn't get shot but you just
off they went and then
now you get to look over their shoulder
while they're teaching these things and
i think it was a good and you saw it in
virginia you saw that was the meltdown
yeah you saw that parents you don't
screw with the kids and i'll tell you
you know there was a lot of democrats
who voted for him because
democrats love telling you how to run
your life until they have to you know do
it to their kids and uh we got to see
the what happens when you do that
because you know you can't make everyone
out to be trump uh you know i want to
mention on the parental rights and
education chat or bill i saw something
in the chicken city chat a couple days
ago and i wish i could remember the
username to attribute it to them but
they said it's not don't say gay it's
wait till they're eight
which is
so much more of an accurate way of
describing the bill and also helps you
understand that it doesn't even go far
enough right well so this is um you
don't want to give the guy too much
attention but
to respond to jankyuger because he
tweeted back at me
saying you guys love to claim the name
as they said or otherwise but it
perfectly describes the bill
i'm like the bill bans discussions of
traditional marriage it's just insane
that they conflated uh a bill that was
trying to prevent teachers from telling
kids not to talk to their parents about
conversations with homosexuality is
egregious like it does a disservice to
the homosexual community yeah and now we
have the fact that you're learning that
teachers are hiding you know transgender
stuff from the listen that's the parents
kid 24 hours seven days a week it
doesn't become your kid teach them how
to write and read and send them home and
if the kid if the parents want them to
read about sex at you know whatever age
hopefully before you know by the time
they're 13 or 14 maybe
but you know there's nothing i've read
the bill it's just it's it's logical now
you know you could say the same thing
about why can't they talk about my
marriage with a man and a woman and no
but
you know i've said this before there's
an over-representation of gay people in
the media there's a lot of gay people
work in the media tons of them
and those people amplify they make up
six percent of the population that's the
whole alphabet characters six percent
and that's you know on a in
they
amplify these causes
to a point where
you know years ago that didn't happen
and you're nowadays it happens because
they're afraid to be called homophobic
for not doing it what we need is for all
of these religious teachers
to just have discussions with
five-year-olds about the bible and then
to tell those kids
don't let your parents know right can
you imagine can you imagine we're
converting their religion against god
well
this is also very important like as a
catholic you would absolutely never be
advised to
baptize someone else's child without
their permission
and also because like as a matter of
justice even though we have the full
truth
you don't own someone else's kid you
don't but besides the idea that but this
is the point that they are such fervent
fanatics
they they own your child in their mind
so when you have this this case in
florida where the the student female
student was getting um therapies and
treatments without the parents knowing
that some of these are permanent oh yeah
imagine if a teacher baptized your kid
oh my god without you knowing and that's
not that's technically permanent but
it's not like altering their body you
know what i mean
it's just you know the fact that kids
are lonely and want to fit into a group
i remember going into the first gay club
and i think the issue was it was that
first moment i ever felt normal because
there were people like me around and
that was 1988 and i can't even imagine
today
what it feels like for them
that now you have to be part of this
group and that if you're not that you
know you're shunned or whatever but you
know i i see a point of it but it's also
a very very slippery slope that you're
making decisions
young i mean i came out in the aids
right dead center of it and
got out of it without a problem because
you know i'd save sex and
that was it but
if you're young these days the
pressure's on you to be something maybe
you're not is permanent nowadays because
you know once those surgeries and all
that stuff happen and then you know
there's a growing evidence of people who
are now saying i wish i hadn't done this
that they're not yeah blair white's
interviewed more than one person i think
that they're saying that this was a
mistake i did it when i was young i
shouldn't have done it i was confused
well the issue is actually the the
algorithmic and media manipulation right
so this ties back to all the stuff
happening with elon musk
when you have
no people to explain a negative
circumstance you only hear a positive
circumstance and so what was happening
was there was a subreddit that was about
de-transitioning and it was people
telling their story saying you know i
didn't have a good time got banned
there was a website got pulled any
instance in which someone said let me
tell you this wasn't that great would
get removed for hate speech because
there was a these these kids would then
only see a positive message right
because it became i don't know when it
happened because being gay you don't
think about it but i guess it was
probably like 10 years ago where
you know the pride and all this stuff
that comes out that you have to
celebrate this you know that that being
gay requires an extra level of
celebration and and it has to you have
to accept it and especially as a parent
you have to accept that i want to be a
man now we went from tolerate to have to
yeah yeah and there's no middle ground
anymore and you know i've said this a
thousand times you know whoever owns the
language
owns everything and if you can say that
this is hate speech because you have
said that these people don't didn't
agree or had a really bad time
transitioning and here's 500 of them
and that somehow offends the other side
that you're not allowed to talk about it
then you're going to create a big and
but that's happening in our society with
everything this goes back to uh the
twitter conversation again in which
twitter's view of everything uh was that
it was it was all filtered through a
leftist lens correct and they kept
saying they weren't biased and i'm and
i'm trying to explain this to these guys
i'm like you're so biased you don't you
don't know you are you are surrounded by
nothing but people on the left no one
but leftist you've never talked to a
conservative so you assume when you hear
an opinion from a conservative it's a
fringe opinion that no one cares about
yes i get it your brother sister and
your friends
agree with all of your opinions you are
not the world right i find that the left
tends to be
it's no surprise they tend to be atheist
secular or outright condemn or reject
religion because they only view they
typically view themselves as the
universe as the universal center and
they're supposedly the most tolerant
which i was hysterical but the least
tolerant people you've ever met in your
life
and it's and it's kind of crazy that but
i think as they lose religion whatever
religion that is as they lose a sense
their religion becomes their identity
their sexual identity well what i mean
is that
people who
if you if you believe there's something
greater than you in any sense be it
spirituality be it the universe magnetic
fields you tend to treat other people
more equally because you're like i am a
person and you're a person and i must do
unto others as i would have them do unto
me but if you think there's nothing
there
well then you're going to be more ego
driven right you're going to be the one
standing on the podium saying i deserve
this right no one else correct that's
what we see a lot of they want everyone
else banned don't you say naughty words
about me you shouldn't be allowed to i
should well i think we're in a zero
tolerance for hurting people's feelings
well and this happened before when i
spoke out on the show
a few weeks ago and just mentioned that
i don't believe in gay marriage media
matters did a write up on the show and
they also made it seem as if everyone on
the panel agreed with me right and it
was actually just you it was the same
they said they said tim castaire
panelists and it was who was it alex
brusowitz
it was uh the three of us and we both
were in agreement with gay marriage and
you weren't and they made it seem like
the whole show was and then media
matters is like watch out for these
grifters who will change their opinions
and it's like not a person here changed
their opinion right they just make it up
yeah fake news you were saying people
don't tolerate what was it exactly
hurting other people's opinions
i think that i think that we're in a
society we're hurting someone's feelings
is violence now i don't i have low
tolerance for malicious behavior if
there's someone's trying to hurt someone
maliciously then i'm gonna step in but
if someone says something that someone
interprets and gets upset about usually
the person that's feeling the upset it's
in their mind right there's something
that they're going through it's like
being at a party with all of us and he
goes i don't really just really not i my
religion doesn't conform to
gay marriage fine i don't believe in it
either like like i
you know i'm a traditionalist in a lot
of senses that don't conform to
what might be good for me just because i
you know everyone's like you have to be
pro gay well no i i think this
institution kind of worked and i'm not
sure that you know but hey society
decided in their own legal ways that
that was the way it was going to be and
so be it
but that doesn't mean that those other
people vanish the day
you know that those court cases came
down those people are still there and
they should be able so what you're
saying for x amount of hundreds of years
of not having gay marriage is the minute
you have gay marriage none of those
people's opinions can exist anymore in
the same space and that
is the problem i have and that is
you can still be in the same room with
someone who doesn't agree that or that
just being gay is horrible or i'm going
to hell i mean who knows you know so the
point i'm trying to make is that those
opinions should be able to exist in the
same space one
doesn't get rid of the other one i want
to point out going back to this meme
from elon i think it's funny because if
you look at 2008
the far left person is actually right
wing in 2021. so going back to what
james was saying about broccoli
so so we we focused on the guy in the
center the me and how the center becomes
you know changes and how his right wing
but if the my fellow liberals stayed in
this spot on the left and moved down he
would he would be right center right in
2021 barack obama
running on universal health care in 2007
in 2008
and now they're calling him a republican
and the drone
king right
killing americans with drones yeah extra
judicial assassination i mean he
even clinton today would be um you know
some of their views and i lived through
that we were talking on the way here was
like what were the 90s like and i just
remember like
did you seem less but see everyone
didn't have a voice and that was a good
thing there was no social media the
person who was crazy screamed at the end
of the road and now they have a twitter
account i think it is time that we start
ignoring
those who drove off the cliff
and i'll just say uh um
you i i am a staunch leftist here who
believes in universal basic health care
and you crazy conservatives oh i shake
my fist at you those other crazy guys
they had nothing to do with this
conversation anymore right this is
there's a there's a new center now
let's pull the center back reassert what
left and right are and the crazy people
who drove off the cliff
they drove off the cliff they're not
part of this conversation i think the
economics for that are there meaning i
think you're seeing it with cnn i think
you're seeing it with cable news the one
that keeps
trucking down the road is fox and the
right immediate right media seems to be
going quite well
and it's the left that seems to be kind
of going off the cliff because i think
that graphic says a lot about a lot of
people in the united states that
consider themselves democrats or left
and now look and go what am i what i
can't i say today when i when i was on
the daily wires backstage live i pointed
out the difference between us here i am
i'm you know i'm wearing jeans and a an
unbuttoned shirt and they're all dressed
very very nice and and and we're all
we're having a conversation where we
mostly agree on a lot of issues like
voting for desantis versus trump i just
think it's funny that the issues that
would really divide us
traditional liberal versus traditional
conservative don't even come up because
they're in the they're on the back
burner compared to the greater problems
we're facing right
and we've faced worse and that's the sad
part like this country's gone through
even in my lifetime my god i got out of
high school and the economy was through
the ground and reagan and you know there
was a lot of we have the cold war we're
gonna die every day from like red dawn
and down for red october like that was
our lives you know and there's this
giant war going on that at some point
russia is just going to be like who are
we fighting considering all that and
people are just like just i don't know
and and the crazy things a lot of
millennials don't realize they were born
during the cold war yeah oh yeah and
their parents were crazy probably
drinking and smoking and that gave us
the millennials because there's got to
be an excuse for how this ended up the
way it did
but what i was saying is i think social
media and stuff about what has changed
in this like when i grew up there wasn't
school shootings and
because kids got home
decompressed they got away from the
bullies they were able to spend time
with that geeky friends go back maybe
get bullied that day
now you have kids that can't ever get
away from this that right they're
connected to this bullying and bad and
good and bad and i think also on the
other end of the spectrum i think in
most societies there's a lot of people
who just don't need to contribute what
they need what they're like just go
scream in the corner you know you know
say it to your parents and stuff but you
there's some people that just don't need
to tell the world like i've seen people
i've seen companies stop advertising and
i think it was harry's
with somebody from a twitter account
that said that they were this company
was it was a date might be the daily
that was they were anti-trans
and the twitter follower had like 38
followers yeah that was harry's razors
and they had so
there's a disproportionate amount of
power that a lot of these people have i
think you make a good point about
evidence for why public schools failing
as well because it's creating an
environment where kids are getting
bullied on the regular whereas this
consistent bullying they they can't
escape it so it's another reason not to
put
people in that environment right
i'm just fascinated that
from where i grew up
you know just going back to what i was
mentioning before about backstage live
is like even having this conversation
with sheamus most of the political
conversations we have are on things we
completely agree on and we only ever so
often touch on the things we don't agree
on even though you and i disagree on
some stuff to a great degree
but the the cultural battles we're
fighting
free speech
individual liberties personal
responsibility all of these things that
used to be just an
american value given it was a given yeah
now it's like okay those other things
are here like we'll discuss them but man
those people are crazy well what we've
gone to now is some people can some
people have different abilities to say
what they can and some people can't you
know a catholic can't say to me that i
don't have a value and i'm not all like
it's we wouldn't say you don't have
value as a person no yeah we would say
they believe homosexual
activity is sinful yeah and you know we
live in a jesse smullet
world where
you know he represented everything i saw
coming down the track and like you're
going to commit this giant crime
to become a victim is you know i
remember when what's her name said she
was black and remember
yeah
and or the first time i heard safe space
and thought
that's never going to take you know and
people like these kids are getting out
of school and they're going to bully
them because they know how to use social
media but social media had gotten to a
point and you're right and i see it in
the media where a lot of these older
editors are scared to death of like
taylor lorenz you know what it is
there's some 40 or 50 year old dude who
works at a company and the millennial
you know comes out and says i'm getting
a job here then they go i demand a safe
room and they go what are you talking
about what are you gonna say from so
then they go on twitter next thing we
don't have a safe room this 50 year old
guy gets 30 tweets and it's like you are
an evil man you're evil and they're like
what's happening
everyone is tweeting at me yeah i've
seen it happen i've seen that happen and
it's i've seen it happen it's not just a
question of what you're allowed to say
it's a question of what the people you
have associated with are allowed to say
or rather who you're allowed to
associate with based on what they've
said so i don't like to pay too much
attention to celebrities but before the
show we were discussing the fact that
chris pratt
is being canceled they're trying to
recast him right because according to
some twitter mob his church is
anti-lgbtq
and we cannot have an actor in a film
who goes to a church that we believe is
anti-lgbtq i just want to remind
everyone i just want to remind everyone
that
the former president of the united
states barack obama
went to a church
with reverend wright
as the preacher who said in a sermon
that was leaked that the united states
government invented hiv to kill black
people barack obama attended that church
for years and when this footage leaked
the media said no that's mean to talk
about and every conservative media went
okay fine we won't talk about that even
though it's literally true thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there